third time lucky
after losing two previous presidential
election bids
sixty-five-year-old ecuadorian bankrupt
businessman
yet mo lasso looks set to govern his
troubled country
gracias thank you from the bottom of my
heart for allowing me to be your
president
so i can serve you facing their worst
economic crisis in recent memory
equatorians preferred to choose the
conservative lasso
rather than swing back to the left to
former president rafael correa's
citizens revolution represented by his
protege
andres araus
lasso campaigned tirelessly underscoring
his middle class roots
national reconciliation and his promise
to eradicate corruption
despite having so many natural resources
we are in this crisis because instead of
working with honesty to solve your
problems
many public servants dedicate themselves
to fighting amongst themselves
and using public offers to enrich
themselves
but lasso who obtained less than 20
percent of votes in the first round
owes his unexpectedly comfortable
victory more to ecuadoran's misgivings
about returning to what many saw as an
authoritarian political party
the korea years were characterized by
violations of human rights
ecuador was one of the most
authoritarian versions of so-called
socialism of the 21st century there was
persecution of journalists
opponents and even unsolved murders of
people who denounced corruption
the challenges for the president and the
country are enormous
unemployment is at the top of the list
the oil rich country's economy has
suffered from a steep fall in oil prices
and the pandemic has only made things
worse
i believe in democracy of course in
ecuador and i believe all of us
ecuadorians know how to elect a new
president to get out of the crisis our
country is in
and the lack of employment that exists
throughout because of the pandemic
the country faces another difficult
problem its steep
foreign debt lasso says he hopes to
maintain good relations with the imf
but is not specified if he will continue
implementing
highly unpopular belt tightening
measures that ecuador agreed to
in exchange for a 6.5 billion dollar
loan
with so much at stake the new president
will have to move quickly
to convince ecuadorans that they made
the right
choice lucian newman al jazeera